I want to start with congratulations on
the movie
um and I mean that sincerely uh
million questions for you if you could
get the financing to make anything you
want what is that project and why well
that's a trick question
[Laughter]
if I could get any honestly um right now
oh my God there's so many well it's like
usually it's like when someone has a
script that they like love that they're
having a problem with it's like putting
like putting it into the world and you
know wishing it to happen no there's
there's a movie I have right now that
I've been working off for probably the
longest amount four years now going on
five maybe at Warner Brothers it was
initially called by all and now it's
called the Untitled Stephen cable Junior
project so now you know how many drafts
has gone through
um probably that one it's like set in a
world where there's like no cops and
people police themselves so it's like
kind of futuristic kind of dystopian but
not always there
um but in the tones of a modern Western
so like
futuristic Western I should say now
um that's probably the one that's really
cool Yaya's attached to it and we're
trying to get that off the ground so I
can make that yeah I'm gonna say I wish
you nothing but the best on that project
thank you sincerely
um you have never played in a playground
this large this is with all the CGI with
everything that went on
um and the thing about it is it's it's
hard to get the keys to this Kingdom to
play in this budget but once you do you
sort of get the keys to other things do
you know what I mean so what was it like
going in or how did you get involved
with Transformers was it was it your
pitch was it the studio coming to you
and you know what I mean yeah no it was
a little bit of both like the first time
that
I did Creed too in the first time in the
studio ever knocked on my door it was
for bumblebee too and I was like I don't
want to do I just came out from Creed
two I don't want to do a sequel you know
and so A year had gone by or maybe two
right before Kobe and they said we found
out the story we want to tackle we want
to bring in Beast Wars I was like I know
all about these wars I'm down for beast
wars and so they developed a script on
their own they passed it to me 2020
October 5th I remember the date and I
jumped right in and I kind of did my own
version of the pitch I said I love where
you guys are going you guys want to do
New York you guys want to do the 90s you
want to do Peru but here's what I'll do
with the characters so I changed up
Optimus Prime I gave him a whole pitch
on how I would start him with like not
loving humans at first and not besiding
Noah right off the rip they're gonna
have friction between the two gave him a
pitch for Optimus primal where they
start off in the top of the movie and I
gave them a new Unicron I mean a new
villain which was Unicron and a Terracon
Squad I just felt like as a fan we've
been tiptoeing around Unicron and all
the other films kind of like hinted
towards him towards the end and I just
really want to expand the universe and I
felt like he was that perfect source to
do so because he tells us there's
another world out there there's more
there's more Transformers out there it's
not just Autobots and Decepticons
and then of course the actual suit that
was my idea is homage to the 80s cartoon
so it was a bit of that pitched it to
him and they loved the heart they love
where I was going with the direction to
the the characters and yeah they kind of
gave me the key to play yeah and and uh
you uh I'm gonna use the term you nailed
it because it's clear like when you're
watching it it's clear a fan is making
this this is someone who knows the
characters I also appreciate the the G1
stuff yeah you know what I mean and talk
about that if you don't mind yeah
there's a lot of stuff I wanted to tap
into G1 because I was a fan there's some
stuff I'm holding off from the G1
because I I'm hoping to be in the next
you know sort of uh phase of this uh
project and there's some sort of like
I can hear the fans and I'm just also
like I know I just wait for the next one
there's some pieces I want to bring back
into G1 in terms of weapons and things
like that that we don't see in this
particular film now I'm just really nerd
talking here but uh I appreciate that
yeah there's some stuff that I like I
know and I'm just like I just want to
get to it but in this one uh just
setting up the fact that you know we are
in that era right so it's like 80s 90s
and I was like I love the designs that
they had it was a lot simpler
um I felt like throughout the years we
started to lose the car into vehicles
within the autobots and so for me I'm
like if we simplify it like they did on
bumblebee we get to keep that texture in
that cool look which makes them special
the fact that they could change from car
to robot and I just didn't want to lose
those parts and those pieces and G1 is
just cool to me what day on set did you
have like a meltdown thinking holy F I'm
directing a Transformers movie oh man I
know the exact moment uh because it's
probably the only moment I've been able
to actually take it in like it still
hasn't even kicked now post post making
the film but there's one day on Machu
Picchu we were shooting here uh
beautiful location so you had that the
setting was nice and Noah his high
altitudes of Noah had a real tough time
breeding Anthony Ramos and he was
running across the field and next to him
was a pole like a another a PA excuse me
a production assistant running with a
pole and a tennis ball and we had just
opened up the park the park was closed
for our park but Machu Picchu was closed
for a whole year because of quarantine
so people started coming into the park
and they were looking down at us as they
were up on the ruins as we were running
across and they were just like run like
they were so enthusiastic run Optimus
run Optimus run Anthony and it was just
like a moment because Anthony was out of
breath we caught cut he's trying to
catch his breath and people were rooting
and cheering for him I just motivated us
all to like let's do the other take you
know because we're trying to get it
right and um it also was a reminder
because like you hear the accents and it
was like people from all over the world
standing on top of this one you ruined
speaking and you're like wow these are
different kind of these people from Peru
could be people from wherever you could
just hear the different accents across
the board and it all simultaneously was
rooting for the autobots and just was a
reminder of how big Prime is in the rest
of the guys Transformers I'm obsessed
with the editing room because it's where
it all comes together so how did the
film change in the editing room in ways
you didn't expect effect and did you
have a way longer like first cut or
director's cut no I I tend to like keep
my director's cut pretty tight uh at
least the one in studio saw was probably
like 15 minutes longer than what we have
now
um but there's small scenes in here that
just cause confusion uh like one was
this autobot or an Autobot this
Decepticon scene Transit that I've been
talking about because Optimus Prime
fights Transit at the beginning of the
movie or at least he used to and you
find out that Optimus Prime wants to go
home like that's all he wants to do and
that's Cybertron is in deep trouble and
uh this this guy Transit was telling him
that like you know we're just here to
kill you AKA like cybertron's already
ours and it was a really epic fight
scene and then you saw Optimus Prime
dump his body in the Hudson River and
all these decepticons were dead and he
saw that he's been hunting for the last
few years so when we screened it people
were like damn it's kind of dark
it was kind of dark but I thought it was
a movie I wanted to make but then I
started to realize it is dark it felt a
little darker
um so we pulled back on that at and then
we started to dive a little bit more
into the maximal sort of origin story
because we were trying to play with the
sort of time travel which is originally
in the mythology for the Beast Wars it
got just confusing and I was like how
can I simplify so a lot of the rewriting
and editing and post became how can we
sort of simplify the maximum story so it
doesn't confuse the audiences and then
one last thing was Mirage uh his jokes
like we were just trying to top the
jokes I didn't write for comedy so it
wasn't until P Davis and got involved
that we started to like rewrite and
change his face to match P Davis and
sort of tone and demeanor with some of
the stuff you cut like the the Optimus
killing Decepticons was that um were any
VFX far along or was this all it was far
along oh my gosh some were like almost
close to final
um I think we're planning on releasing
it for the fans that's what I want to
know I want to release it I won't
release the the Hudson River him
dropping the bodies because that wasn't
far along because I was totally CG even
the world
um so we had a mixture of boards and a
mixture of previous for that one but the
other stuff with him fighting Decepticon
we had render shots it was a really
tough call like the studio like it took
us a couple weeks to figure that one out
because we all loved the scene and we're
trying to make it work but it's just
slowing down the film and kind of like
people already understood that he wanted
to go back home they didn't need that
extra piece this movie had what are you
actually as a Transformers fan because
you are I think this is my last question
what are you most looking forward to
other Transformers fans like Easter eggs
and things that like fans are going to
really appreciate I don't know if people
ah this is a good question there's a
moment in the film now where I don't
know who's gonna catch this uh or where
Scourge is about to kill Prime no spoil
alerts and he lifts up his blade and
he's like Primus would be ashamed and
like I feel like that's one of the first
times we actually mentioned Primus in
the storyline and the fact that now we
have the ability to not open up the door
and tap into where the Autobots actually
came from and who are they I think I
feel like when I'm talking to my mom
she's like I love Transformers but like
what are talking robots and where are
they from and I'm like now I feel like
in the next films uh there's Easter eggs
now in this film that we can set up to
say hey we want to go further into that
direction and explain things like that
so that's probably an Easter egg only
fans would probably get I know I gotta
go but just real quick would you ever
debate having prime say one shall stand
one shall fall with Scourge or was it's
like that's the animated movie we can't
touch that uh you know if we can carry
it over Lorenzo is doing an animated
movie so if we could bring that over
that'll be great
um but I think that'll be fun to play
with for sure uh especially in the next
one to come yeah I love that line yeah
anyway I gotta go congrats I hope he's a
huge thank you for your time